[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
einige von euch haben sich noch ein paar
halloween edlen gewünscht also gibt's
heute halloween okay da anfangen wo bild
aber ich lasse ihn jetzt schon egal
ihr könnt auf jeden fall schon mal auf
meinem blog in der app und natürlich
hier auf youtube in der playlist
vorbeischauen denn da gibt es schon
einige halloween ideen
dieses jahr habe ich mir gedacht weil
das donuts video bei euch so gut ankam
die pumas und donuts mache ich einfach
halloween donuts draus das heißt ihr
habt hier die donuts können sie wirklich
unterschiedlich dekorieren und da kommt
noch eine blutige füllung mit rein
ich stelle jetzt erst mal ein hefeteig
her das ist nämlich die basis für die
donuts und dafür brauche ich folgende
zutaten für den hefeteig verwende ich
einen würfel hefe zwei esslöffel warmes
wasser 50 gramm zucker 350 gramm mit 2 1
und 2 eigelbe etwas vanille extrakt 800
bis 850 gramm mehl einen teelöffel salz
und zimt und 70 gramm weiche butter also
hier habt ihr alle zutaten wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr sogar den teig
einfärben dann sind sie noch ein
bisschen gruselig aber ich lasse sehr zu
und macht dann später gegner so einfach
farbig ich nehme sie den zucker da wird
die hefe dazu geprügelt und das wasser
kommt noch ein
berührt die zutaten und dann lasse ich
diesen vorteil einfach für etwa 15
minuten stehen
so geht später der hefeteig nämlich auch
noch schneller auf und das ganze könnte
jetzt entweder hier machen oder direkt
in der küchenmaschine da kann ich
nämlich die hitze noch einschalten auf
etwa 34 grad
dann geht es noch ein bisschen schneller
und vor allem seht ihr sodann auch auf
eure hilfe wirklich gut ist und ob der
teig später auch aufgeht dann nämlich
viele ein problem und sagen mensch der
teig ging nicht auf
ihr müsst einfach auch schauen dass
natürlich die hefe gut ist und so sehe
ich das dann auch den vergleich
jetzt ist die hefe aufgegangen und ich
kann den teig fertig stellen
das heißt ich geh jetzt einfach alle
zutaten rhein bei mail mache ich es
immer so erst mal nur ein bisschen mehr
als die hälfte die eier und das eigelb
da habe ich jetzt einfach mein basis
donath rezept genommen und noch mit zimt
verfeinert
heute geht es mehr um die deko und um
die füllung vanille extraktes noch drin
und die milch die habe ich bereits
erwärmt dafür könnte nämlich einfach
dass er mein schälchen auf den herd
stellen kurz erwärmen und dann die milch
direkt eingeben dann anschalten
jetzt wird der teig richtig schön
geknetet und ich kann jetzt nach und
nach noch das restliche mehl dazu gehen
jetzt auf die mutter mit dazu und kann
einfach sein je nach milchsorte dass wir
800 oder 850 gramm mehl braucht ich habe
jetzt auch ein bisschen was übrig
gelassen
ich gucke nämlich immer erst mal nach
der konsistenz verfügen kann ich dann
immer noch unter teig sollte einfach
weich sein aber eben nicht mehr kleben
und das kleben das verschwindet auch
durchs knet und den teig lasse ich jetzt
für etwa sieben bis zehn minuten kneten
damit er richtig schön geschmeidig wird
jetzt ist der teig fertig und ich hätte
jetzt die arbeitsfläche ein bisschen mit
ball ans brett mit dem teig daraus und
freue mich jetzt einfach kurz zu machen
ihr seht auch das geht jetzt nicht mehr
schön weich und geschmeidig
das wäre dann eine schöne kugel habt
könnt ihr die schüssel auch nochmal
fetten die teig kugel hineinsetzen und
auch die oberfläche vertrockneter teig
nämlich nicht aus weil ich hab mich eine
zuschauerin gefragt warum ich manchmal
nehme und manchmal packt rinspeed
es ist so wenig merkt der teig ist noch
ein bisschen zu weit dann nehme ich
gerne mail und streu praktisch mail in
die schüssel und auch mal oben drauf bei
mädels aber das problem
das ist beim auf gehen einfach so ein
bisschen plump und ich will keine
klumpen in meinem vertrag haben also
nehme ich die meiste zeit eigentlich
back transport und jetzt 20 den teig
schon aufgeben und jetzt überlege ich
mir noch eine füllung denn ich hätte
gerne dass die donuts richtig leckere
füllung haben
also ich das jetzt angedachten blut okay
ich überlege es mir gleich macht blut
und kann rein weißen zurück ich dachte
eigentlich so an die damals von globus
dem immer so eine leckere nook abfüllung
nicht überlegt mir jetzt schaffen teig
aufgeht wenn die eiligen eine blutige
füllung will dann kriegt sie eine
blutige füllung also machen wir jetzt
zum einen eine frucht füllung dafür
nämlich 250 gramm himbeeren 250 gramm
johannisbeeren die sind aus dem
tiefkühlfach den jetzt bekommt man sie
einfach nicht mehr regional und frisch
dann habe ich hier 50 gramm stärke und
100 gramm zucker den zucker den könnt
ihr natürlich auch variieren weniger
oder mehr nehmen je nachdem wie süß
einfach die früchte sind jetzt gebe ich
einfach alle zutaten hier in den topf
guckt mal das sieht doch schon blutig
aus oder das wird gut 30 zeigen muss
also halloween ja jetzt auch mal wird
sich so für die kinder vor allem aber
ich muss es nicht haben also keinen kein
feiertag oder so der unbedingt bei mir
sein mussten
aber ich find's ganz witzig immer mal
rezeptideen dafür zu machen
ja ich nehme jetzt auch erstmal nur die
hälfte des zuckers schmeckt dann gleich
ab wird sie die stärke reihen und
erhielt das ganze jetzt erstmal auf
niedriger stufe damit die früchte
einfach auch schön auftragen können wenn
ihr vorher daran denkt könnte sie sind
natürlich auch in der mikrowelle kurz
auf trauen lassen
wenn ihr eine habt oder bei
raumtemperatur und ich früher das jetzt
schön damit sie einfach langsam aufbauen
[Musik]
guck mal mit dem wacker könnt ihr die
früchte wirklich super zerdrücken und
damit könnte auch ganz gut gefrorenes zu
drücken hackfleisch zum beispiel auch
oder könnt auch lokales oder gekochte
kartoffeln zerdrücken und zerstampfen
echt total vielseitig und vor allem geht
es viel schneller als mit dem
tragschrauber und dem schneebesen geht's
halt nicht so gut weil der sich alles
fängt um sich der schnee wir sind dann
eben verformt bei gefrorenen dinge mit
jetzt habe ich das hier schon zerdrückt
jetzt kann ich es auch etwas höher
stellen und wirklich schön einkochen
lassen
jetzt ist die masse schön eingedeckt und
ihr könnt sie entweder so lassen oder
einfach durch ein haarsieb streichen
oder das fleißige lieschen benutzen ich
nehme das fleißige lieschen aber ich
streiks noch so durch dann seht ihr man
kann es auch als ganz normalen haar
sieht benutzen und eben auch ein ganz
normaler sie verwende man nichts
besonderes dafür und so kann ich jetzt
die kerne entfernen und dann denke ich
den pudding an der oberfläche direkt mit
frischhaltefolie ab damit er keine haut
bildet
ich liebe hefeteig guckt euch das mal am
bug der ist so schön weil es echt schön
nämlich den teig heraus und kann ihn auf
1 cm stärke ausrollen
schwupps schon wieder klein
[Musik]
das geht so auch ganz einfach denn ich
habe hier einfach diesen ring
draufgemacht drauf gedreht da hat direkt
ein zentimeter stärke also keine titel
sammeln
jetzt ist er schon perfekt jetzt braucht
ihr einfach nur zwei ausstecher ich
nehme es hier einmal 8 cm und etwa 3 cm
jetzt mal ausstecher nicht gefunden also
nehme ich einfach natürlich stehe ich
jetzt hier die donuts aus zuerst außen
und stand ihnen den übrigen teig könnt
ihr entweder verkneten oder ihr packt
diese kleinen runden kreise direkt als
kleine karpfen aus so wie ihr wollt
und da nehme ich jetzt donuts und damit
ich später beim frittieren nichts an den
donuts kaputtmachen lege ich sie direkt
auf dem backpapier also auf den
zuschnitt und das seht ihr auch in
meinem grundrezept video
so kann ich nämlich die donuts noch
einmal für eine halbe stunde aufgehen
lassen abgedeckt und dann damit direkt
ins frittierfett gleiten lassen
dann bleiben sie richtig schön
[Musik]
die donuts sind jetzt aufgegangen und
ich werde jetzt hier in der friteuse
frittieren seht ihr auch alles in meinem
grundrezept video bei 150 bis 160 grad
also wirklich nicht so heiß im kochtopf
könnt ihr auch nehmen aber wirklich
nicht nicht zu heiss einstellen ich war
verwirrt weil da so ein blitz war aber
es war nur ein foto blitz und jetzt am
besten direkt auf einem schaumlöffel
geben
und gleich aber das papier aussehen
entweder der eine zange oder ihr lasst
das papier gar nicht erst mit ganz rein
plumpsen ich nichts sagen und werde
jetzt die donuts von beiden seiten etwa
zwei bis drei minuten zitieren
gerade noch gesagt data und das papier
könnt ihr auch dann gerne bisschen
abtupfen und danke nochmal benutzen
zu viele donath solltet ihr übrigens
auch nicht ins frittierfett geben denn
dann kühlt auf einmal ab und dann ist
auch nicht gut verwenden nämlich gleich
diese zwei messer und setzte dann
einfach umdrehen und fertig aus baku
[Musik]
die donau hat sind jetzt fertig den
restlichen teig praktisch gerade noch
aus so als mini krapfen und ich lasse
jetzt hier ab kühl und wenn sie danach
dann gefüllt und dekorieren jetzt ist
der zeitpunkt gekommen an dem ich die
daumen werde dafür nehme ich hier eine
fülle
falls ihr sowas nicht habt könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch diese einwegspritzen da
nehmen also diese plastik spritzen jetzt
auch in der apotheke jetzt in apotheke
oder ja und die hatte ich auch immer die
sind auch super praktisch und wir hatten
die halt auch immer zu spielen aber die
hab ich natürlich getrennt ne die einen
zu spielen also keine sagte clinton
ich meinte als kind zu bespielen und
diana manhart für die küche ok guter
moral keine duktus spielt dann nehme ich
ziehe die creme die füllung die farbe
ist perfekt finde ich richtig lecker es
riecht lecker probiert hat mir so nett
doch vorhin beim zucker abschmecken
da habe es probiert und es war lecker
spritze der held hat schon so halloween
weiter transplant
falls sich auch psycho manchmal okay und
jetzt sucht ihr euch bei eurem donath
die schöne oberseite aus als die
oberfläche und dreht s&p es bis hier ein
und spritzte verlor ein und das macht
ihr einfach ja so viel wer möchte sein
wenn ihr viel füllung haben wollt dann
macht er fünf sechs löcher rein und
piekst rein und wenn ihr es nur
punktuell haben wollt dann eben ein
bisschen weniger rein theoretisch könnte
man den donut wiegen und dann weiß man
auch wie viele schul und drinsteckt
mache ich jetzt unsere gucken ob es
wirklich auch
mit sind die donuts alle gefüllt
ich finde okay ein bisschen sie jetzt
schon aus wie so ein stichwunden auf der
haut es sieht ein bisschen danach aus
ich habe jetzt hier bereits cora türe
temperiert das heißt zwei drittel über
dem wasserbad erwärmt dann runter
genommen ein drittel dazu und bisschen
kokosfett so hat jetzt die perfekte
temperatur und jetzt kann ich hier die
donuts mit dieser seite eintauchen
[Musik]
kurz abtropfen lassen und dann hier auf
eine abkühlung gitter geben und es darf
ruhig seitlich so ein bisschen runter
tropfen fällt dadurch sehen sie noch
besser aus luftbläschen schlag ich jetzt
hier auch noch raus
für die anderen donuts werde ich jetzt
eine zuckerglasur verwenden
dafür habe ich hier einfach puderzucker
mit etwas zitronensaft und wasser
verrührt dafür hier das rezept auf
meinem block 1 werde ich weiß lassen
dass andere orange werben also gelb und
rot mission gelbe und rote
lebensmittelfarbe passte
jetzt das ist doch eine richtig tolle
farbe wird auch ich dabei
die donuts sehen ja so schon ziemlich
cool aus vor allem farblich also ich
find my camp sofort das ist halloween
donuts oder kann mich nicht mal die
klappe und jetzt können sie entweder so
lassen oder ihr nehmt zum beispiel diese
halloween deko fledermäuse totenköpfe
geister messer was man hier noch nochmal
geister und die könnt ihr hier auch
drauf geben ich nehme jetzt noch die
zucker schrift und male damit hier diese
spinnweben drauf das heißt ihr fangt
jetzt hier an und mal das erst mal ein
kreuz zum beispiel ihr dürft auch gleich
dekorieren
[Musik]
ich lasse es hier immer aus der mitte
heraus und dann machen wir hier noch
zwei nutzte schleife drin nicht schlimm
mama war hier hat es mit zuckerguss
lecker oder du isst ja die ganze
zuckerglasur
und wenn ihr diesen punkt dazwischen
habt könnt ihr sie einfach mit einem
zahnstocher bisschen verbinden
so seien die donuts auf ich habe mein
halloween party sind jedoch ziemlich
cool
ok marcel ich weiß schon wo ihn sein
blick geht ist natürlich schokolade wir
wären ja möchte ich wirklich schokolade
das sind diese hier und ich glaube wenn
man jetzt sagt okay ich möchte jetzt
keine spritztechnik draufmachen legt
wirklich einfach die halloween deko
drauf und ihr seid fertig bitte selbst
und gab anregungen nicht ganz fest je
mehr schokolade bekommen desto besser
ihr wisst machst du eigentlich hier
reinkommen können in dem kostüm
halloween video er zeigt sich nicht so
gern wirklich grund siehst du die hölle
los
ich habe ein bisschen ich habe ich ein
bisschen was abbekommen
also es ist die überraschung am 11 und
jetzt mal eine dumme frage wie lange
dafür gebraucht oder so realistisch wie
denkst du wie lange braucht man dafür
also realistisch gesehen ohne kamera
ohne filmen denke ich kommt man schon
ganz gut in zweieinhalb bis drei stunden
das lässt sich also noch ordentlich ganz
gut für eine party machen auf jeden fall
und wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich habe gar
keine lust selber zu machen dann holt
euch donnert und deko ist einfach fertig
das war eine halbe stunde
aber seltsam war samira ok samira hat
den besten deko tipps
sie hat hier einfach dieses messer drauf
geklebt und noch mit schwarz mit zucker
schriften zucker schrift in roth samira
zeigt euch hier jetzt noch den deko tipp
das finde ich glaube ich noch cola
vielleicht kann sie den sogar so einem
messer einstecken und dann so aus man
nahm ihn einige male aber voll gut weißt
du warum weil die füllung der austro
tisch dann sieht es auch sonst wird die
füllung oben mein gott das ist voll die
gute idee kommt kurz noch mal kurz hier
live und jetzt steckt so bisschen rein
[Musik]
wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen weil es
nicht fest ist tatsächlich wollte
einschneiden und reinstecken die donut
sie sind halt so war ich so und jetzt
hier lasters blutsturz etwas total
samira macht das nicht so gut weißt du
warum kommen gleich der rödiger und
buchte ich als promoter für dicke backen
nächsten es doch ok ich muss zugeben
ganz ehrlich das hier ist der beste
platz das mit den spinnweben samira hat
den besten tipp ja ich glaube masse ab
sofort ist sie die chefin der muss ich
natürlich auch noch später probieren ja
dem ist dann auch noch probieren und ich
gebe jetzt einfach main kanal ab
ja was mir sogar den geistern im rotary
aktives kind sag ich da nur
also wenn ihr wollt dass eure kinder
kreativ werden könnt ihr die donuts
verbreiten und wer grad geben
und ich würde mal sagen tschüss bis zum
nächsten mal
mir macht an dieser stelle weiter kommst
du denn auch die kirche auf
[Musik]
nein